I shot minor [ __ ] high school fail I
left my past behind me I said to myself
if something's bad you have to leave it
I started over in Germany with nothing I
wanted to try it out on the last day of
my life I would regret it if I hadn't
taken this step you only have one life
to live give nor ie one mocked us what a
mock doesn't the oldest of four children
pratt inna cross was born in southern
thailand in 1967 thirty years later she
came to germany and married a german she
trained as a hotel manager and worked in
a variety of fields before getting the
chance to take over a Thai restaurant
protein across who calls herself mayo
didn't hesitate in 2012 she opened the
restaurant dowel by mayo with him here
eine kleine it's like a miniature
Thailand here I like to cook and I like
being with people interacting with
people and making good food are my
strengths for me it's very important to
introduce people to Thai culture
Thailand is equal to ax I [ __ ] a
brighter whiter retina grass also runs a
cooking school right above her
restaurant she offers courses twice a
week revealing the secrets of how to
prepare authentic Thai specialities
Pratt ena is known for her curry dishes
based on time-tested family recipes
she makes the curry paste herself it's
what gifts the dishes their special
flavour
[Music]
ozune I come from southern Thailand the
famous islands Phuket and Koh Samui are
about 500 kilometers away from my
hometown it's about 30 kilometers to the
Malaysian border we southerners like to
eat curry it's a specialty among us just
like roast pork is in Bavaria Thailand's
cuisine is simple but very versatile
first the spices come in the wok and are
browned fish sauce is used instead of
salt only at the end are the meat and
vegetables added gentle preparation in
the wok keeps the flavors strong and the
vegetables crisp
[Music]
often only a few minutes are needed to
prepare the food it's lean cotton kokin
is minor Laden shaft I would love to
cook it's my passion if I can cook I'm
happy you can't think if you're hungry
in Thailand we greet our neighbors or
friends with the question have you eaten
yet the way you'd say how are you over
here when I see that everyone likes the
food I've made I'm happy that's me
Venus glucose can start in Berlin
Charlottenburg district is sometimes
called little Chinatown no other part of
the city has as many Asian shops and
restaurants the restaurant doub I'm a
all fits in this Asian scene but stands
out nonetheless that's due not only to
the food but also the decor much of
which protein across picked out in
Thailand herself
[Music]
with her restaurant and her cooking
school she sees herself as a bit of a
cultural ambassador Magee with us even
food plays a very big role for us ties
it starts when a large group of five or
six people go to a restaurant everyone
orders something but all the food goes
in the center and everyone shares it
Allison
it's different here everyone orders
their own dish but in Thailand we
ordered jointly and eat together protein
across doesn't use flavor enhancers like
monosodium glutamate in any of her
dishes fresh herbs and spices bring out
foods natural goodness sawatdee-kah
Bonnie Mayor Tom Kane who a green guy
hate on Jennifer Tonia Roy Dafa KOB Khun
kha